victoria's secret is trading in the
angels
for megan repino they're trading in
people traditionally considered to be
sexy for according to the new york times
people who are
not they are doing that because
the very idea of making oneself
desirable to another person
is now considered wrong unjust
and bigoted you've seen a lot of tick
talks going around
tick tock i guess i actually i'm not on
tik-tok because i don't want to give xi
jinping all of my data
but you do see these videos going around
youtube are going around twitter
from tiktok and a woman explained
the even even murkier more bigoted
orange in the origins of fat phobia it
doesn't just come
from anti-fatness it also comes from
racism here's your reminder that fat
phobia is rooted in racism
as always if you haven't read this book
go do that
the main thing to understand is that for
the last 300-ish years
white folks have been marketing fatness
as a black trait
and this is regardless of whether or not
black people individually were actually
fat
that was irrelevant the message they
spread was that black women specifically
were ravenous and uncontrollable
and these barbaric traits made them fat
on the flip side
thinness was marketed as a white trait
again regardless of whether or not
individual white people were actually
thin
that was irrelevant the idea was that
white women specifically were refined
and restrained
and this led them to having delicate
thin bodies over the years these
messages have become more subtle but
even today they are still very prevalent
in conversations around race health
capitalism and poverty
so so fat phobia is
the well i guess literally it would mean
the irrational fear of fat people but
that's not what we're talking about here
which means fat phobia she means having
a preference
specifically a sexual preference for
people that you find more attractive
than other people
and if you have that if you have just a
natural attraction that's bigoted
that's racist and she's saying that fat
phobia
the by which she means just being
attracted to people you're attracted to
that is rooted in racism because
terrible white people all those white
people
marketed the idea that black women were
fat regardless of the individual black
women
now do you notice the logical error
there
she's saying it's terrible to generalize
about black women
which is what although all those white
people did well aren't you generalizing
about the white people
you're willing to get specific and
individual about the black people but
not about the white people because
there's a complete
double standard because this argument is
incoherent but it's it's just designed
to get at a deep racial animus and she
says this is was
awful let's assume that her premise is
true that in popular culture black women
were
considered to be on average more likely
to be fat
that's just true that's that's true
that's actually one of the reasons
that the coronavirus was tougher in
black communities than it was in white
communities
it's because in certain black
communities they were more likely to be
obese and
obesity was a co-morbidity obesity was
was considered
to be a factor that would put you at
greater risk so
yeah that that's true you're denying now
statistics the right facts that we can
see from the
cdc and from from other agencies
is that it's a hate fact you're not
allowed to acknowledge that
no because if you acknowledge that fact
then
you're perpetuating inequality well it
wouldn't it be better than
to just like try to solve the problem
well no if you try to solve the problem
and deal with these health issues in the
black community which we have been told
is is very important part of inequality
is that there are worse health outcomes
in the black community
okay well then perhaps we should tell
people who are obese to lose weight well
you can't do that because that's fat
phobic well then what on earth are we
supposed to do
you're supposed to feel bad about
yourself and you're supposed to deny
your attractions and you're supposed to
hate your self and your ancestry
and you're supposed to upend nature
oh is that all okay that's fine that's
what that's ultimately what it comes
down to there can be no solution to this
there can be no victory
oh hey there oh hey sorry i didn't see
you there you should ring the bell right
now
and you should subscribe and make sure
you get the notifications and you should
also head on over
to the apple podcast and spotify and
google play and all that to subscribe to
the audio
oh you're probably yeah right this is my
upcoming book speechless controlling
words controlling minds
it's available now for pre-order but
it's coming out super duper soon so make
sure you pre-order your signed
autographed both it'll be both signed
and auto raft first edition copy at
premiere collectibles you can also get
on amazon barnes and noble anywhere you
get your books
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]